Limoilou et 15 juin dernier la Seine à
1h de déjà-vu le Québec est secoué par
un 13e féminicide en 2021 derrière la
tragédie il y a une heure tu es et 3
enfants dans le deuil c'est quelque
chose qui n'a jamais accepté avec
Catherine genoux a vécu avec sa mère
Nathalie pichet et celui qui allait
t'être accusé de l'avoir tué Noureddine
Mimouni et tu l'as vu leur histoire
d'amour devenir toxique violente au
point de devenir scène de meurtre
de jalousie de possession
j'ai toujours fait comprendre la jeune
fille avait 19 ans lorsqu'elle partager
leur logement les signes de discorde ne
manquait pas entre sa mère et Mimouni
et qui sauve des vies toutes les femmes
ont pas à quitter leur maison à aller
dans une maison d'hébergement mais tout
peuvent recevoir de l'aide au téléphone
ou par des rendez-vous en personne et je
pense que c'est le premier pas qui a
décidé de parler c'est pour inciter les
femmes à demander de l'aide avant de
subir le même sort que sa mère